[Music]
[Applause]
tonight two fans named J and Rob say
they think they caught a mistake they
say it happened when I was interviewing
guest John Leguizamo it's going on going
you messed up pretty bad man so they
don't not yet John Leguizamo on the TV
show with you and you told him oh you're
the only person ever shoot out but she
know that movie you have the distinction
I looked it up on the internet you're
the only person to ever shoot and kill
Al Pacino in a movie no completely wrong
you ever heard the movie Scarface kind
of a smaller film yeah nobody's ever
heard about it huh come on man the guy's
coked out he gets shot a hundred times
the guy the glasses comes out shot them
straight to the stomach he's going into
the pool blood everywhere
yeah I'm pretty sure he's dead in my
books I don't know what you're thinking
about I don't know what you're reading
all those who's giving you the script
but man you messed up bad see yeah well
sorry
Jay and Rob but you are the guys who are
dead wrong Al Pacino was not killed at
the end of Scarface here's the ending to
Scarface that the whole world if you
stayed in the movie theater knows
juvies me mother
[Applause]